bring in Ron Jaworski the former Eagles
quarterback former ESPN NFL analyst and
all-around good guy how's the arm jaws
not as good as it used to be dad I could
probably uh play arena football now on
the 50-yard field that's about it what's
the furthest you could throw a football
84 yards in my prime I could zing that
thing 84 yards in fact I remember the
day I did it I was having a little
contest with James Harris when we were
quarterbacking with the Los Angeles Rams
we played a Thanksgiving Day game in
Detroit and the day before that game we
had our practice there and we were
seeing who had the stronger arm
I barely outdistanced James Harris but
his 84 yards I think a lot of people
aren't at least I'm under the impression
Randall Cunningham had maybe the
strongest arm in the NFL yeah I mean I
was played with Randall for a couple
years he was clearly the most gifted
athlete ever played a position in my
opinion he had all the attributes you
want from the quarterback position but
then when I never lined up and said hey
who's got the stronger arm and actually
the strongest arm I ever witnessed that
I saw was my wide receiver Harold
Carmichael 100 yards believe it or not
he was 67 big long arm a big old hand
and he can throw it down the field Wow
Harold Carmichael could throw in a
hundred car like it was great and I'm
still trying to process this Andrew Luck
situation here of it is it could it be
something as simple as you just go home
and your wife says you don't have to do
this you're newly married baby on the
way she's seen you go through this for
the last four years five years six years
I look what am I missing here of just
being able to walk away at that position
at that age yeah I didn't I don't think
you're missing anything you know I was
fortunate enough to play in the NFL for
17 years you know with with four
different teams in Philly Los Angeles
Kansas City and Miami there were times I
was thinking of quitting and I talked a
lot of other players about this since
Andrew had decided to retire now a lot
of guys have that same feeling
and the feeling comes from not because
the athletic ability of the competitive
juices we all have that and that's why
you played professional football the
body wears down it was like every injury
I had a broken leg torn ligaments it's
six to eight months it's everyday Dan
every single day in the trainer's office
being dealt with athletic trainer
getting healthy six months three four
hours a day to get healthy then you play
the season you may get hurt again you
have to do it again and there are times
when doubt creeps into your mind do you
really want to do this the quality of
life gets lost
we heard Gronk the last couple days
talking about football is a game of
passion you have to love what you do
it's a violent you get beat up violent
games you get beat up physically and
sometimes you lose that passion and
after three or four years I think Andrew
Luck just said my body can't take
anymore
three or four years of dealing with this
pain every single day to rehab to hard
work get healthy also to get banged
again he's had some very serious
injuries I think he I don't Andrew just
a stand for days he's a class act as
everyone knows one of the finest people
he's ever mean I'm not talking about
being a quarterback I'm talking about
the person he is I just think the
cumulative effect of all these injuries
just wore him down but is he a football
player or a guy who played football
loving I mean there's a difference in
that in but you got the guys who are
lifers you'll play through pain and
they're just football players and then
you've got guys who are you know a
person but they're really good at
playing this sport it feels like Andrew
Luck is that kind of guy
where's Grady is more of a I'm a
football player yeah I wait from my dogs
Venge what he's a football player I mean
you know his dad is Oliver Luck you know
the former NFL quarterback you know
there was the West Virginia versus
athletic director now heading up the
commissioners ship of the XFL so he's
been around football his old life and
your luck yes he's been in Europe he's
been obviously in Texas where he played
he's been you know he's been everywhere
in regards football I think he's got a
burning desire to succeed at the end
a level but I think the injuries just
warm down what's the most interesting
quarterbacking situation for you to
watch this year probably Dallas right
now you know and I heard you before I
came on talking about you know Dallas
draws you know the eyeballs in the ears
and I think with the situation within
Dallas right now and dak Prescott right
now without Ezekiel Elliott that's an
interesting one drug one to watch for me
because there's no question that team is
fueled by the running game and and and
certainly dak has fit into that with his
play-action passing and mobility and has
played very well but I think you know
without Ezekiel Elliott who knows how
long it's going to be I think dak is
relegated to a much more of a caretaker
for that offense yeah but it doesn't
feel like he'll be able to do that if
Zeke's not there he's going to be asked
to produce plays to make plays and I
think we look at dak Prescott and and
you'll understand this there are certain
quarterbacks in history who managed a
game it wasn't about their numbers it
always feels like that's what dak does
you don't necessarily ask him to win but
I think you're gonna ask him to win if
Zeke's not there he does that very well
by the way you know III I love his game
I don't think he's a top-ten quarterback
he's certainly a you know maybe in the
next five in that regard to evaluate all
32 quarterbacks in this league he
probably moved up a notch with Andrew
Luck retiring but certainly he is a guy
that can make all the plays he's gotten
better I just wrote the year was
phenomenal he had a little bit of a fall
back year too but I think he's gotten
better as a quarterback but I look at
the reads the mechanics the anticipation
that has all improved as his career went
on but we all know how Dallas and likes
to play football they like to run the
football they like to use the
play-action pass again and it won't be
as effective if you don't have Ezekiel
Elliott in that backfield he's Ron
Jaworski former Eagles quarterback
former analyst at the mothership I
Paulie brought this up yesterday
now Paulie you want to tell jaws what
you thought of the Eagles uniforms
well I'm not anti you girls I think
they're a good team great franchise I
think the Eagles color green is too
bland and to doesn't really embrace the
tradition of the Eagles I liked it when
you played the color and also the kelly
green that the
at times do you agree yes absolutely in
fact if you ran a poll in Philadelphia
you would find out that most fans want
to go back to that that former Eagle
green that kelly green that was so
prevalent that's been changed a few
times I'm not sure how many cubes of
green there are but I sit like like the
kelly green and i know the fans would
love it at least have a throwback game
or the third uniform in that kelly green
jersey and i'm all for that
who do you expect the Eagles to play in
the Super Bowl I'm glad you said that I
didn't think you're gonna ask you about
the Eagles haha this is a very good
football team in Philadelphia now get we
you know I don't want to throw out the
well we know the game is played on the
field not on paper but Howie Roseman
Jeffrey Lurie Doug Peterson have really
assembled a lot of talent on this team
with a great deck and of course you have
to look around to the AFC since you
asked me which team I think will be
there I think this is an Andy Reid
season I think this year the Kansas City
Chiefs get back to the Super Bowl
so I'm looking at Eagles Chiefs in the
Super Bowl in Miami your biggest
question for the Eagles this year will
be oh we know the answer you guys head
asked me that about every team it's the
quarterback position you know
fortunately the Eagles got a veteran
quarterback and Josh McCown who can fill
in if anything does happen to Carson
Wentz but clearly if you look at the
history of Carson Wentz injury wise and
we all know some of that is just
unfortunate luck Carson Wentz has to
stay healthy for this team to get to the
Super Bowl that simple but I can say
that about the Patriots I could say that
about the ranch I could say that about a
lot of teams but does Carson ones play
differently this year I hope so I think
it's imperative that he does he's got to
change his DNA I had one thing about
Carson he will not give up on a play he
will fight for every yard and sometimes
the best thing to do is to give up on a
play throw it away don't take the sack
don't take the hit when you're in the
open field get down on the ground get
out of bounds don't take those
unnecessary hits I'm telling you I said
it to him I know the coaches
said it to him they'd probably tell him
that every day but he's such a fierce
competitor he does not want to give up
on a play because he's very athletic and
he thinks he could make every play but
there are times these NFL defense win
jaws is currently doing film sessions
features with players for NFL Network
NFL Films what's the film that you're
gonna watch today I'm probably going to
look at the answer look because he was
one of the last film sessions Brian
Balder and I did and by the way Adair
thanks for mentioning that
these pieces that were doing through the
NFL Network and in conjunction with NFL
Films you know we get the players we
send them for two three hours and just
look at tape and have a football
conversation and it's amazing the
personalities that come out of many of
the athletes you know hey like I said
Andrew Luck was one of the last guys we
had you know Malcolm Jenkins just very
impressive when you sit and talk
football and personality and the fans
love the X of X's and O's and what NFL
Films does along the film network they
integrate those sounds you know we got
players wired every single week and
you're in the huddle with teams it's
absolutely awesome and I just love doing
these because we just sit there you know
put out the TV and watch football jaws
will be watching great to talk to you
again and we'll hopefully catch up
during the season dan you know where to
reach me love you on the show thank you
thank you John that's Ron Jaworski for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]